hey welcome to education I'm Kevin Smith
and I mainly become free oh my god we
got some good crap to give away today
man we've got a bunch of the same usual
prizes and a bunch of cool new prizes
and so I'm rambling like I'm Tara Reid
let me slow it down we've got some very
cool prizes that we just put together in
this box like mere minutes ago right
before we left the house I was busy this
morning I went to Disneyland with my kid
and so I got banned then and when we got
back we went to veggie girl now I sound
like a brand [ __ ] [ __ ] like I'm just
naming brands and [ __ ] but that was my
morning and afternoon and sin I got back
and II came over we put together the
prize package and stuff and now here we
are but Andy has been working overtime
because he came up with a quiz full of
[ __ ] questions is that right yes this
being a quiz that we're all at I did yes
we have some real stumpers this time but
you know somebody I you know the idea of
writing these questions is everybody's
not going to know every question or
every answer but somebody in the room is
going to know the answer to at least
every one of every single one I I you
know the questions are worded a lot
better than I was just talking yeah I
handed you the mic to make sense of this
all and you're like how my homina homina
a couple of Tara reads alright man
without further ado we will jump into
the quiz do you have the questions I do
they're right here sir the edge of a pub
quiz is about to begin folks put your
hands together so the folks at home know
your real
we are as always here at the scum and
villainy Cantina on Hollywood Boulevard
here in Hollywood California man we got
a nice crowd ready to play the game and
stuff we have ten rounds of questions
for you're all prepared by Professor
Andrew McHale for not a real professor
and boy oh boy at the end of each round
you're gonna walk away with something
did we pick out a wooden spoon or we did
not I don't think we did it wooden spoon
talk we need a wooden spoon JC like a
shitty prize for the end for the people
that do the worst all right I got some
shady stuff yeah the rest of the [ __ ] is
all good prizes man ten rounds of prizes
the first round ladies and gentlemen is
the Terry Fox prep round that's because
we had a lot of extra uniforms for the
Terry Fox prep school sequence in yoga
hosers of [ __ ] ton and so I said let's
make a whole round of questions about
high school movies and or TV shows so
the winner of this round walks away with
three screen-used Terry Fox prep
uniforms actual teenagers wore the tops
and bottoms and sweat stains yeah some
lady last week was like mines got stains
I was like you're a bigger winner okay
so this week Andy came up with questions
for the Terry Fox round movies with high
school in the title that should make it
easy right very much instantly your
brain should be moving toward every like
High School Musical how many how many
movies have the word High School in it
and that is not one of the questions
don't start writing alright fair enough
here we go ready folks do you have your
cards put your phones down nobody could
look up the answers that would be
flat-out cheating so phones down folks
we see you using your phone we're gonna
embarrass the [ __ ] out of you in front
of a bar full of nerds phones down pens
up as we begin round one the Terry Fox
round put your hands together let's
begin it with energy
man here we go Terry Fox laughs yes yes
[ __ ] here we go number one what is the
full title of High School Musical 3 yes
looking for the full title you all so
much
we're all in this together I'm trying to
think and I can't remember
you've already stumped me [ __ ] I'm a
loser number two what high school movie
features four songs by the Ramones and
one by Brian Eno got an excited table
over here
I was excited as well if you could have
saw the blood rush it went right to my
nipples because I knew the answer that's
what high school movie features four
songs by the Ramones and one by Brian
Eno meanwhile I'm number three here we
go what 2012 highschool stoner movie
featured Snoop Dogg and Wiz Khalifa in
title roles yep real movie I'm thinking
oh really yeah good to know what 2012
high school stoner movie featured Snoop
Dogg and Wiz Khalifa in the title roles
and number four Jon Lovitz starred in
what high school movie with Tia Carrere
she was his love interest really yes
you actually preposterous did you watch
the movie that movie Jon Lovitz starred
in what high school movie with Tia
Carrere turns out to be Andy's favorite
it's not my favorite and number five
folks the last question the round these
are what alts or those are for if we
never get the other thing I was like
holy [ __ ]
number five this is one that closes out
the round ready Janeane Garofalo Camryn
Manheim and Alan [ __ ] were the
supporting cast in what 1997 comedy
starring an Oscar winner ooh what could
it be
I knew this right away yeah Janeane
Garofalo Camryn Manheim and Alan [ __ ]
with a supporting cast in what 1997
movie comedy starring an Oscar winner
good pull yeah there you go man there
your five questions that make up around
one the Terry Fox round when you're done
filling out your card ladies and
gentlemen hold it up in there and wave
it like this and Nate or Big Daddy Jimmy
V are gonna come by and grab your cards
take them in back which is really the
front and tabulate them and figure out
who wins the rounds and when you're done
finishing out your card hold it on out
folks all right finish those cards out
and full and they will come collect them
how long does it take you to put
together a list of questions to be
honest this one took about six hours are
you [ __ ] me now that's a steep
investment of time well I'm trying to
keep the internet off my back so every
question I write I have to go in
research intensively did you take [ __ ]
for the last game at all the previous
game he took [ __ ] for the what was it
the the Friday the 13th yes it's still
fresh I still feel I still feeling that
well I when I took [ __ ] for this time
was that Amidala
was her chosen princess name but she was
born with a different name god Padme
Amidala but I said what is her maiden
name and legally when a woman gets
married it's the name she has before she
gets me so you were right they were
wrong there's a gray area
oh that Bell means nothing all right
everybody n we should count down and
make sure all the cartoons do we have
all the cards in here we go 5 seconds -
this round closes ladies gentlemen 5 any
cards left 4 3 2 1 [ __ ] you that rounds
over put your hands together ladies
gentle we accomplished something in the
expanse of human endeavor this is
something it is a minor compliment but
it accomplishment nonetheless shall we
go through the answers now we shall all
right man help me out you've got the
answer key teach number one what is the
full title of High School Musical
through three Andrew musical three
senior year and we'll just take senior
year as you are I know it's a
bittersweet time wait High School
Musical 3 what did they start and
there's
for years well as I'm assuming if you
work backwards
yes but they never mentioned if they
were sophomores in the first movie as
far as I recall I only saw it 17 times
because my kids were you know 7 and 10
at the time I remember that [ __ ] all
right here we go
what high school movie features four
songs by the Ramones and one by Brian II
knew you know Andrew well the Ramones
did the title song and you might recall
the song rock and roll high school
what 2012 high school stoner movie
featured Snoop Dogg and Wiz Khalifa and
the title roles why that would be Mac &
Devin Go to High School we got some Mac
& Devin fans back here wow I've never
heard of that really yeah I watched it
when I was doing that snoop show so I
got you know get a little insight Mac &
Devin DVI n go to high school I just
learned something number four Jon Lovitz
started what high school movie with Tia
Carrere
you might remember his hilarious fro
from the poster why it was high school
high and then number five Janeane
Garofalo Camryn Manheim and Alan [ __ ]
were the supporting cast in what 1997
comedy starring an Oscar winner and that
would be [ __ ] Romy and Michele's high
school reunion
that's right Mira Sorvino later y know
had won the Oscar had won the Oscar
fighting Aphrodite and this was the
project she did right afterwards yeah
Lisa Kudrow had been in the Broadway
off-broadway version of it or there was
a play it was well I think they did it
here in Los Angeles it's one of the five
she did alive it was a live show and she
created that character in somebody else
did the other care
they kind of brought him together they
developed they workshopped it at the
like Sunset Boulevard that old theater
that that's now knocked down they built
the big towers
that's like La Cienega uh-huh I forget
was called but alright anyway very cool
that's a little trivia for you folks
you've got the card right there which
means we must have a winner we have a
single card which means a single winner
with four correct answer what a team is
it Andrew it is quiz or voir dogs you
have won these five shirts
what up Zack give it up for the winner
of round one man all right but that's
just the pass and we don't live there
we're in the future man that means we're
on to round two
round two ladies gentlemen is entitled
tease me this is the tease me round
that's because in this round we give
away t-shirts that I don't wear anymore
because they're too big and the will
wouldn't take them so Malcolm wouldn't
take them so you're looking at like this
one is a two XL t I don't know where I
got the T from this one is a three XL as
is the other one is a Captain America an
x-men shirt and this is an Avenger shirt
all from the fine DXL large man store
where I do most of my shopping these
three shirts will be yours
if you answer these five questions
correctly place your phones down ladies
gentlemen pick your pens or pencils up
and get ready to answer me these
questions five that doesn't really run
number one what is but yet to say what
it's about the whole theme for the t's
round is about the is about ice-t the
rapper and I you themed the whole thing
- yes ice-t ladies and gentlemen and II
wanna culture I comp laws for being
clever so give him his [ __ ] applause
I wanted that was a cheap applause line
for
all right so all the questions have to
do with iced tea yes [ __ ] man so if you
don't know anything about iced tea
you're [ __ ] in this round here we go
what is iced teas real first name
what is iced teas yeah my first name
Arnold Palmer
hey Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy Big Daddy Jimmy
Jimmy V do you have your sheet I need to
see it
I've questions and answers is this
correct should I keep going is that
right yeah yeah okay we'll go with this
did you write these while you were drunk
or something no I wrote the questions
many times a recision yes all right
number two folks iced tea got his name
from what pimp turned author whom Dave
Chappelle Lyon eise's in a recent next
Netflix comedy special so ice tea to
honor a famous african-american writer
who had been a pimp and a criminal most
of his life made his name ice-t
based on this guy's name what is his
name that's the question designed to
[ __ ] everybody
yes somebody might get it I think there
might be someone in the audience that
knows that number three what was the
name of Ice T's heavy metal group
responsible for the release of cop
killer the song cop killer started a
whole feud with the LAPD with that one
ice-t had a heavy metal group what was
the name of that heavy metal group man
no copying on the papers over there
number four what character does ice-t
play on law and order : SBU what
character designs to play on law and
order SVU you know it's actually played
it on four different TV shows really
yeah he was on 30 rock as that character
on Chicago PD is that character and on
Law & Order but for the last nine years
he's played this character on Law &
Order SVU
you went deep on ice team hmm and number
five who played the voice of iced tea in
an animated show that originally aired
in 2015
animated show in 2015 that featured iced
tea as a character I'm sure there might
be a few people in the room that know
that one
yes but it's one thing to know that but
who played the voice of iced tea I think
an educated guess will get it right in
an animated show that originally aired
in 2015 that is question number five
folks that means all five questions of
brown to the teased me round have been
asked so if you fill out your card once
you've got all your answers hand them
over to Big Daddy Jimmy B or of course
Nate and they'll collect them and then
they'll tabulate them and we'll figure
out who the winner is man but that's all
the questions we got from round two hmm
and if you didn't like the iced tea
round the good thing about asking those
questions that will never ask them again
notes there will never be an iced tea
round again know what the silence fell
over the head as we were all like I know
I don't know enough about iced tea right
unless like boba fett takes his helmet
off or whatever and it turns out to be
iced tea that's it for Ice King we're
done it'll never happen again
hand in your cards folks so we can move
forward to give you the answers right
everybody in most difficult guys get
owns nobody no more cards on this side
Nate in five seconds five four help me
count it down kids three two one bang we
did it put you
together we finished round two [ __ ] it
it's over all right Andy this was a real
nut biter of around so get ready to
answer for yourself what is ice tea's
real first name Tracy right yes that I
did not and his middle name is Lauren
Tracy Lauren both names that are both
are non gender-specific names just to
elucidate yeah that's true iced tea got
his name from what pimp turned author
whom dave chappelle lionize isn't a
recent Netflix comedy special that would
be iceberg slim iceberg slim no iceberg
slim fans in the audience but she
wouldn't let him write it down
number three what was the name of Ice
T's heavy metal group that was
responsible for the release of the song
cop killer body count oh my god I forgot
about that body body count
I have that cassette number four what
character does ice-t play on law and
order SVU all right we that is fin
Tutuola and we would take fin or
detective Tutuola and he's played that
character on four different shows yes
and then number five what know who
played the voice of ice-t in an animated
show that originally aired in 2015 now
the show was Rick and Morty Rick and
Morty who did the voice and it was Dan
Harmon who did Ice T's voice really yes
Dan Harmon who said that it was the
biggest regret he had from the season is
that he couldn't get the actual ice-t to
do it so he's as an open offer to ice-t
to be on Rick and Morty and if he is
we're doing another ice-t round
no bones everyone just gasp like never
again god damn it there it is whoa oh
[ __ ]
what is that's a lot of cards yeah does
that mean there were a lot of people
that did everybody win two three
help us out what's going on what do you
motor you muttering to yourself what
your team's we'll do some we'll do some
playoffs here will do slapping the desk
how many let's count them right or now
in Systema two three four five six seven
Jesus man there's only three shirts this
answer for the cop-killer question the
Nate the heavy metal group they put was
there goes the neighborhood
all right read off the names the team we
will take one representative from each
of the following teams ready let's get
jumping up here short troops short
troops we need a rep up here short
troops Reservoir Dogs quiz quiz one
who's the boy dogs boo urns boo urns
great admirable I'm sorry admirable
snackbar that's funny
snack bar get somebody up here
it's a Twix let the Wookiee win let the
Wookiee win we'll take a representative
up here suckas and biscayne suckas and
boss boss tour bus came from [ __ ]
Empire PAH Keystone gin & tonic key song
gin and tonic he sound gin and tonic
come on alright so we should have seven
people when all said and done yes one we
have all seventy four or five six seven
Jesus that's a lot all right how do we
do this well we'll ask the question I'm
gonna ask the question and you watch and
the person who slaps first you pick them
do not answer until Kevin picks you okay
everybody's gotta have a hand over the
bar here we go alright yours is kind of
low Jamie there you go
all right here we go Andy you got seven
hands ready to slam and I'm looking at
it at all of them okay ready
yes what does ice tea's wife Coco Austin
do for a living reality TV I'm sorry
that is not her profession no no I'm
sorry
yeah but model she's a swimsuit model
would you take but model for swimsuit
model can you go budding in the ocean no
no
so I'm sorry so now that you know the
answer we have another question that was
where we got three left because the
other ones that are answered incorrectly
they're out the round
there are three rounds so now we got
three people go sit down well done folks
but the ones who have not three left or
four four left here we go watching
watching the hands what does SVU stand
for what team what is it
Ram what was the team phone you guys are
suckers and boss suck is impossible on
the shirts man give it up for does that
foscam boss yay that was adorable boss
kay that was like my dad going like pick
up your boss cave figure alright here we
go folks
round three man this is called the brats
around because the winner of this round
walks away with a scream used Brasi from
the movie yoga hosers right there man
don't applaud no that's the workout
that's the workout one yeah he's missing
his little gear and stuff but yeah he
was on set right there you're gonna walk
away with a piece of cinema history he
said with a smile on his face
round three ROTC round is always themed
to monsters and this time around the
questions are themed specifically to sea
monsters so here we go man phones down
pens up get your cards ready and answer
this where where the location shots done
for jaws where was all the locations
shooting done for the motion picture
jaws
they did shoot on the universal lot but
that was not location shooting miles you
don't have to explain that [ __ ] these
people are smarter I was explaining it
to you you never got explained to me by
the party here we go number two what
cast member of sharknado played the bad
guy in the Andy Mikkel first written
white chicks the movie white chicks what
cast member of sharknado played the bad
guy and he also worked on that script I
did not work on sharknado no but on
white [ __ ] I did I'm just giving you
credit okay thank you I appreciate it
number three according to The Hollywood
Reporter who was originally cast to play
the president in sharknado 3 oh hell no
which was the name of the movie yes it
was and this was picked up by the all of
the newspapers because it was it turned
out to be an interesting answer and what
here's this 2015 2015 who was originally
cast to play the president in sharknado
3 number 4 what underwater monster
movies theme song written and performed
by one of the stars features
synchronized swimmers in its music video
that question is dripping with clues see
it's an underwater so there was good
what underwater monster movies theme
song written and performed by one of the
stars features synchronized swimmers in
its music video Wow excuse me number
four five number four or five in 20,000
Leagues Under the Sea
what creature does Captain Nemo
slaughter in the Antarctic big
slaughterfest in that famous science
fiction book and this from the book so
in the book and the through the movies
yeah they do
how close to the movie is the book where
book is the movie like 60 years but
there's differences I don't know how
much there was all that beautiful
upholstery in the book but I just
learned today that there are massive
differences between the movie Bedknobs
and Broomsticks and the book Bedknobs
and Broomsticks Wow which gives the kid
the book the kids never go lived with
eglantine they lived with their aunt and
she was the lady who lived next door
no that's number one bless you well I
mean like 101 Dalmatians love the book
came out after a change there it is the
end of the round folks throw your hands
in the way or wave them like you just
don't care if you got a pink card in it
or whatever color it is all right
because it's all pink give it up to Big
Daddy Jimmy B and Nate they will collect
it from you and they'll go tabulate our
winner in the next room and all right
any cards up cards up ladies and
gentlemen into the round in five seconds
five four three two one yeah we did it
ladies and of around put your hands
together we are accomplished all right
Andy take us there man were where the
location shots done for Jaws I was going
to say Martha's Vineyard it is Martha's
Vineyard Martha's Vineyard yes a good
second-guessed question as an East Coast
thing what cast member of sharknado
played the bad guy in white chicks and
would be the ubiquitous Jon heard Jon
heard yes remember at the end of white
chicks at the white party he was the guy
that revealed that he was never mind
number three according to The Hollywood
Reporter who was originally cast play
the president in sharknado 3 oh hell no
why of all people it was Donald Trump
Donald Trump was cast in oh hell no what
you're telling me is we're living in a
sharknado reality exactly correct
here we are watch the skies number four
what underwater monster movies theme
song written and performed by one of the
stars features synchronized swimmers in
its music video well you know LL Cool J
was that singer and he would not do the
movie if he died in the movie if the
black guy died so he agreed to do it if
he lived to the end and that movie was
the deep blue sea deep blue sea Wow
I didn't realize that Wow good Paul and
I should have [ __ ] I could have pieced
that together if I reverse engineered it
this synchronized swimming was the
thrower the other stuff wasn't the clues
yeah yeah number 5 in 20,000 Leagues
Under to see what creatures kappa nemo
slaughter in the antarctic it is Kevin's
favorite whale the sperm whale sperm
whale Wow well he you know what I can't
tell you if he did or not because in the
book in the book he he was he was trying
to be a champion for the underdog and
the sperm whales were killing the
Antarctic smaller whales and so he took
the Nautilus and using that that
sawtooth front of it
he just gored all of them and cut them
all in half and killed hundreds of sperm
whales that's in the book yes it is the
book is very exciting Wow
I mean I don't know if I'd call that
exciting but that's I could see why
Disney left that out of the movie like
we shot up the kids were crying for that
whole scene Wow the results are in
really have three teams that will come
up and compete for the bra team three
teams are gonna compete for the broad
sea folks and Angie's gonna tell you the
name of those teams right now they are
team ramrod ramrod a representative up
here obi-wan kibou see obi-wan kibou
zzzz send a representative of everyone
kibou Zee
these are not the shots you're looking
for quiz avoir dog because of our dogs
did it again
and somebody's end up Zack or somebody
else hey here we go all right here we go
hands over the bar gentlemen I'm
watching close Andy's got a question for
you as soon as you think you know the
answer slam that bar hard man winner
walks away with that screen-used prace
Andy take it away this is movie quote
and you have to get the quote exactly
right
what does chief Brody say after seeing
the shark come up out of the water for
the first time in Jaws I'm sorry that's
not exactly right no I'm sorry that
isn't correct I'm sorry it's you're
going to need a bigger boat
so we'll go again well that we get yes
we do that was tricky what two-time
Oscar winner played chief Brody and jaws
two-time Oscar winner are you [ __ ]
[ __ ] me all that jazz you are not
children of the 70s
you can't answered Nate a French
Connection French Connection to all that
jazz can I answer can boys Eider that is
crazy business I don't have another
question so let's do another John's
question you pick it this time all right
okay
you watch their hands I'll do the said
he didn't like John so he's already out
you watch the hands ready okay what is
the name the last name of the boy whose
mom slaps chief Brody you [ __ ] are
breaking my heart yes Brody
no no Smith no but good guess Rodriguez
Kentner boys man hit there boy did you
come up with another question let's see
No we'll get there let's see I mean if
they didn't get Roy Scheider [ __ ] let's
go with what was the name of the town of
the island that jaws takes place on an
island said a medieval heaven evil
that's incorrect they're wrong I was so
excited to just say everything Island
day no here we go hands over the bar
ready what is the name of the boat the
captain Quint takes out to sea with
Brody and who burn Jesus I can't be any
more clear it was also the name of a
movie years later not to be confused
with a richard harris underwater monster
movie about a creature that the boat was
named after y'all know jaws is a shark
right yeah this is actually the best
thing that's ever happened to me
everybody
the Oracle there you go jaws is based on
a book written by what author Peter
Benchley we give it up for Wow so now
you see having Jaws expertise like that
wins you a prize yeah man it's worth it
what team one that what do you want
Oh buddy go we wanna lose you walked
away with a bronzy well done all right
here we go it only took 19 tries here we
go man Round four is the raw round
ladies and gentlemen in the raw round
you walk away the winner of this fine
little weed package right here
comes to the rolling tray comes a a
little doob tube holder comes with a
pocket ashtray comes with it's
essentially a kit to get you started in
the world of competitive marijuana
smoking yes and while it may seem that
the decorations are nice I feel like the
fact that all the paper is all natural
with no dyes or chemicals actually makes
it more healthy did you think they were
sponsoring us they're not but they do
send me a lot of fries we're going for
that sponsorship we do we want them to
realize what a good deal this is so the
raw round ladies and gentlemen is always
weed related questions and this week's
weed related questions are famous
stoners what does the Rolling Stone did
a list of 50 famous stoners and these
are people from that list so if you I
just wanted to say somebody else's fault
if they're not a stone oh you're laying
the blame on rolling yes all right from
Rolling Stone man famous stoners Andes
pulled five questions put your phones
down which pens up here we go round four
is about to begin the raw round doesn't
get any Rohrer than this
number one he did the original book and
series now hosted by Neil deGrasse Tyson
that Bell means absolutely nothing
he did the original book in series now
hosted by Neil deGrasse Tyson and he was
his donor famous stoner all these people
are famous stoners number two real name
Robert Zimmerman he is rumored to have
turned the Beatles on to pop we're
looking for the name of the guy whose
real name is Robert Zimmerman and such a
famous stoner he turned the Beatles
themselves onto pot he's got a different
name you all know him by and that's what
we're looking for number three his
father was convicted of assassination of
federal judge John H Wood jr. super big
stoner and famous I know this his father
was convicted of the assassination of
federal judge John H Wood jr. category
one from famous donors to
pressing sorry assassination there's no
excess number for he created the
character Porthos the Porthos creator
and famous stoner is it he's famous and
he was a stoner
hence famous donor this is the yes
really yes that's interesting to me I'm
gonna learn something today number five
the last question in the round folks
he played Roger Murdock in airplane and
was arrested several times for
possession does actor played Roger
Murdock in the movie airplane
exclamation point and was arrested
several times for marijuana possession
marijuana possession including two times
at the Canadian border hey [ __ ] man no
so he's arrested by the Canucks of the
Americans I think the Canadians on the
way and they saw him coming interesting
all right here we go man that's it the
end of the raw round round for once
you've filled out your card hold it up
and Big Daddy Jimmy be there or Nate
will come right those card that's the
cards over here to take them out back
and they'll tabulate it as yeah a lot of
people scratching out and rewriting
really you've seen people like
correcting themselves again putting the
correct answer out and putting a front
one in okay where everybody in looks
like we don't have any more cards five
more seconds the end of this round count
it down folks five four oh one more
three two one
before it's all done in the history
books you got your answer keeper off I
got it ready not a real prop here we go
he did the original book and series now
hosted by Neil deGrasse Tyson the
original book in series I believe you're
talking about is cosmos cosmos and that
would be Carl Sagan Carl Sagan bitterly
obsessed owner billions he talks like a
kid that got stoned for the first time
in college and is looking at his hands
imagine billions and when put through
that filter I had no idea suddenly it
made a lot more sense I think he was
kind of stony yeah real name Robert
Zimmerman he's rumored to have turned
the Beatles onto pot I'm gonna guess
that this is the only Rob Zimmerman I
know Bob Dylan Bob Dylan ladies and
gentlemen Bob Dylan's real name hot
smoker secret identity Robert Zimmerman
and it was a David Bowie wrote an ode to
him where he says here's to Robert
Zimmerman just so you know there's a
song that will commitment all right
number three his father was convicted of
assassination of Federal Judge John H
Wood jr. I'm gonna take a shot in the
dark here at pun intended
yes woody harrelson what he Harrelson
ironically named the first name I got
that right I can't believe it man yeah
that is kind of an ironic name
considering he killed the guy named wood
yeah weird okay number four he created
the character of Porthos they also
create d'Artagnan he did Alexander du
monde was a STONER was a STONER he wrote
about smoking smoking up into him really
yes Wow good company we got some happy
people over here no they're dying
there's some people I mean come on and
then number five he played Roger Murdock
and airplane and was arrested several
times for possession is that Robert
Amy's it was Kareem abdul-jabbar
three Madeline that's right yet a weed
thing at woman yeah you got the vector
Victor Roger Roger
yes oh my god Wow excellent [ __ ] Paul
that was a nut butter nicely done Nate
give it a little piece of performs give
it up for Nate ladies and john make
collection cards one winner of that
round yes one winner and they got four
correct they thought instead of Kareem
abdul-jabbar it was Steve Guttenberg the
team is Buehrle take your booty well
done my friend
smoke up in good health all right man
we're at round five ladies and gentlemen
the epicenter of this little game of
ours round five is the education round
man
it's the titular round if you will the
round based on the podcast that is based
on the book that is based on the podcast
that this podcast is also based on it's
also this is the education book y'all
see it the winner of this round walk
away with three signed copies of
education as written by Professor Andrew
McAfee give it up with a beautiful
foreword by mr. Kevin Smith you could
win this book or you go to Amazon right
now and buy your own copy so if you lose
this round don't worry you can go buy
one if you'd like man but that we
encourage that not because it's a just
get auntie's or my friends in Philly can
get it at the Franklin Institute which
now started telling you which is my
hometown Science Center
I'm sorry I feel like I have arrived you
certainly got the pity applause all
right here we go man the education round
is about to begin in the category here
all the questions are derived from past
episodes no no this is that we're moving
on to new territory we don't talk about
two of these people in the book but I
thought I'd make a whole round out of
celebrity inventors celebrity and whoa
people he wouldn't probably think we're
getting patents but they were I bet you
I know one of these okay here we go man
pens up phones down and answer me these
questions 19 what's the name of the
famous old Hollywood actress who is
credited with creating bluetooth in the
new Netflix documentary bombshell his
documentary on Netflix called bombshell
and there's a famous old Hollywood
actress old Hollywood he's supposed to
can old Hollywood actress she's a famous
old Hollywood actress from back in the
day yes very back in the day and she's
credited with creating the modern-day
Bluetooth technology what's your name
yeah I know this story number two what
director has a number of patents
including one for an underwater dolly
and it's not like an underwater like
Barbie doll it's a dolly for cameras
they meant like an underwater Betsy
wetsy what director has a number of
patents including one for an underwater
dolly what would you pick Betsy wetsy
you wouldn't know if she was wetting
underwater that's why I would get this
one I think so far I'm two for two yeah
oh yeah
number three famous for riding
motorcycles what actor patented his
design for a bucket see now this one I
would take a shot in the dark out but I
think I might get I didn't know about
this bucket seat business but most games
are about guesswork to some degree can't
know everything right like I watched a
lot of Jeopardy and I would say three
out of ten or total guesses and you know
they're right that's good yeah
the rest of the seven I know so I know a
lot of this but this one would be a
total guest number four
this artist was famous for painting
paintings with four faces he also
patented a watch with five faces who is
it this artist was famous for paintings
with four faces but he also patented a
watch with five faces if I face watch I
mean I'm I'm John jurist
I'm shelling the dark of night you can
you can have like New York Tokyo he did
patented yes sir Wow and then finally
folks the last question the round five
the education round what famous rock and
roller is a toy train nut which means
enthusiast and has seven patents related
to model trains are you [ __ ] me I am
NOT [ __ ] you this is the nut vital I
don't know this and I couldn't guess it
goes to if you are a model train
enthusiast you are a nut I'm going out
on tunnelling with that we're standing
we just lost all the model train
enthusiasts yeah at home no I [ __ ]
this show what famous rock and roller is
a toy train enthusiast and has seven
patents related to model trains see then
I lose right there
I'll get that one yeah I don't know that
at all that's the end of the year round
folks the last question you're gonna get
you can wait as long as you want but
there will not be another question in
that round that round is at an end so
when you're done finishing your filling
out your card hold it up man and the
sweet Big Daddy Jimmy B or the sweet
Nate are gonna pick up your cards take
them out back tabulate the [ __ ] out of
them and tell us what the winner was or
who would the winner has been the
meantime I ask you good sir how is that
documentary on Netflix it is excellent I
know he has a very strange origin you
know her first movie she did was in
Germany and it was she was naked it was
like a nudie movie
and so when that followed her to
Hollywood you know she escaped to the
Germans she was of Jewish heritage
heritage and she almost could work but
luckily she was incredibly beautiful and
smart so she ended up being famous that
name I just had a discussion about that
name regarding not related to her but
it's short for ahead big is it isn't
that weird it is weird
I thought head drew maybe you're saying
okay any more cards left out there Carly
said giving away the answers counting on
the end of the round and five four three
two one got that round it's over put
your hands together we did something
round five ladies and gentlemen the
education round name for the book that's
name for the podcast number one what's
the name of the famous old Hollywood
actress who is credited with creating
bluetooth in the new Netflix documentary
bombshell while that would be Hedy
Lamarr Hedy Lamarr Hedy Lamarr ladies
not to be confused with Hedley Lamarr
from Blazing Saddles that's true but now
explain the Bluetooth thing because
Bluetooth didn't exist then but she
created whatever it is that for the
military they she came up with a system
that would work like a player piano and
instead it would switch around between
frequencies using a similar system of
player piano she worked with another
inventor they patented it and it was
ignored by the military and then
purchased and kept off the market by the
military until it opened up after 50
years and then it became Bluetooth so
[ __ ] up she invented it 50 years
before and she made this much money from
it absolutely nothing to make any money
yeah just spent money on it she gets all
the credit now though yeah let's see
number two what director has a number of
patents including one for an underwater
or dolly why that has to be king of the
world James Cameron James Cameron Jim
Cameron late for the movie if he has
anything to do with water it's gotta be
Jim Cameron man
number three famous for riding
motorcycles what actor patented is
designed for a bucket seat
I'm gonna guess Steve McQueen Steve
McQueen is correct
Wow good bull did you know that a
Highland Avenue and Santa Monica Avenue
that intersection is Steve McQueen
Square why it's just they named it after
where if you drive by you look up on all
the corners and it says Steve is Queen
Square on it
although there's a story like that's
where he died [ __ ] how they just
named it after him for him that's your
story
this artist was famous thank you nay
this artist was famous for paintings
with four faces but he also patented it
a watch with five faces and that's got
to be Andy Warhol Andy Warhol that is
correct
so somewhere in the world there's a
watch with five that goes all the way
around your wrist yeah I've never seen
that that's cute
okay and the last one was what famous
rock and roller is a toy train not has
seven patents related to model trains I
do not know that you got elusive that
would be Neil Young Neil Young look
kidding me is a big model train
enthusiast alright so there were your
answers for the round
it seems we got a few that's where I got
the line it's better to burn out than it
is to rust from his little train from
that know how many wonders you got why
we have two winning teams with the venom
and I will take a representative up here
from the following teams Andy admirable
snackbar admirable snackbar get up here
and pirates of Alderaan appearance for
the Pirates welcome up here I thought it
was Pilates of Alderaan but it was
pirates Pilates all right now if there's
- do we still do the we can do the
back-and-forth game now yeah do that one
that's fun yeah you do that
I like that alright so in this game it's
it's what is it word association they
just go back up in numbers I'll give you
a category and you have to name
something from the category we'll go
back and forth and completely at random
I will start with you because I know
there's a lot of answers to this one
so you'll begin and you ready face each
other face each other
this is head-to-head competition the
category we're playing is Steven
Spielberg movies Steven Spielberg movies
so all you have to do is name Steven
Spielberg movies at each other in a
threatening way we're gonna start with
you until you run out go and hold on go
you got three seconds between each one
two three did you lose already what the
[ __ ] was that it oh my god give it up
for the winner ladies and gentlemen oh
my god me share the wedding they're all
fantastic job well done guys
it was a spectacular flameout man you
like until we forget the ball and then
all of sudden he was like oh wait I have
to name a second one yeah there's more
than one well done everybody walks away
a winner all right the education round
is over folks round six begins and this
is a genre gems in the genre gems round
it changes from week to week from genre
to genre the prize you're playing for
are these two fine-ass [ __ ] books
from the good folks at inside edition's
heavy listen to this you heavy ass books
man one about ghostbusters
what about Back to the Future these are
coffee table books yes you could put
these out with pride and have people be
like oh he's a rich man
look at how heavy these books are inside
edition's is a high-quality four or six
color publisher and we love them they're
fantastic they make [ __ ] great books
so these two books are what you're gonna
win if you can answer these questions
genre gems round six and the category is
rom-coms this will accompany romantic
comedies if you hate it ice-t you are
gonna really know this one this has very
specific rules to it so you might want
to listen very closely as Andy explains
what you have to do here it's not a
simple answer the question go ahead
telling what it is well in romantic
comedies what happens is young actors
tend to be in a number
of them in a certain part of their
career so in this game Kevin is gonna
read you three movie titles and you have
to name the actor that's in all three of
those rom-coms it's a little tricky one
but you know we got to try some new
stuff now and then fair enough I like it
all right here we go
question number one man I'm giving you
three movie titles you just have to
write down the one actor and or actress
correct that that they share or an
actress not and or there's not two
people that answer it
okay so just actor or actress fair
enough we were separated by our common
language here we go number one she's all
that head over heels down to you hmm not
if she's all that fans in here I got
that one right I'm winning already
number two down to you The Prince and me
a guy thing I sound like the movie phone
dude yes welcome to Moviefone people
whom most kids like what's that number
three well I see what you're doing here
a guy thing Heartbreakers kissing a fool
a guy thing Heartbreakers and kissing a
fool
number four kissing a fool since you've
been gone the Paul Bearer probably his
most famous rom-com kissing a fool you
since you've been gone the Paul berry
I'd agree with that and then number five
the Paul Bearer bounce thanks for
sharing
so you see what I did there I did so
there the last clue and each one is the
first clue in the next one but that's
nothing to do with it's a different
actor or actress but I wanted to prove
that if you were in a romantic comedy
you have herpes because they share it
all they're all of the same movies to
Stu of gross super Hollywood herpes
you've proven your point you've shoved
it right in the face of our betters
there it is man that's round six cards
up everybody faster
man cards into Big Daddy Jimmy V innate
who will go tabulate and then we'll find
out who was great and won that round
round six John were gems is coming to a
close folks cards up there's another
card right there Nate Yan way and I
think that's about it man so you got
five seconds your cards gentlemen five
seconds to the end of the round five
nope
carts for when we run the card to one
it's over put your hands together man we
got done with that [ __ ] alright Andy
this is good man tricky this genre gems
number one she's all that head over
heels down to you I'm gonna say Freddie
Prinze jr. Freddie Prinze jr. mr.
pie-o-my lpj yeah damn it yes alright
alright the next one down to you the
prince and me a guy thing former rom-com
Queen Julia Stiles Wow these Styles got
some high fives on this table good Paul
I would have lost that one this one I
think I know a guy thing Heartbreakers
kissing a fool got to be Jason Lee that
is number four kissing a fool since
you've been gone
the Paul Bearer I'm gonna say can I take
a guess David Schwimmer David Schwimmer
I got it I know my swimmer I'm swimming
in it you're four three four four I'm
crazy good at rom-coms at number five
the Paul Bearer bounce and thanks for
sharing this I was I was befuddled by
this except I could take a guess do it
Gwyneth Paltrow Gweneth the minute
herself all right there was man round
six John were gems well done Andrew well
put together tricky woman I figured I
had to suffer through the movies you
guys had to suffer through my question
that was fun and it was clever and it's
resulted in one winner one winner
we need one word
some of the following team to come up
here and accept these two amazing inside
edition's books as your prize for the
genre gems round six rom-com round Andy
what team is that winner I want to be
the first to extend congratulations to
team ramrod team yes your books team
ramrod well done well done well done
good job alright man round six in the
books round seven is about to begin
ladies and gentlemen round seven we call
the Smithsonian Museum round these are
questions that have to do with me Kevin
Smith and this week it's about the movie
dogma and you are gonna be playing
you're gonna be playing for this Jay and
Silent Bob strike back Monopoly game
signed by me and mr. Jason Mewes there
it is right there so these questions
I better get all these right and I hope
I got all the right I know right yeah
Smithsonian Museum around 70 pounds
begin put your phones down pick your
pencils up and here we go ladies and
gentlemen number one how much money does
Rufus claim Jesus owes him it's funny I
can't stay the line in your head and
then immediately you feel bad how much
money does Rufus claim Jesus owes him in
dogma
all these questions Dogma related number
two
William Donohue ran what organization
that famously protested Dogma without
ever seeing it I remember these he's one
of the newspaper articles about it a lot
of trees were felled by those folks as
they went after us number three Silent
Bob's lying on the train is a reference
to what movie that came out ten years
before Dogma Silent Bob doesn't talk
much but when he does boy does it count
usually he steals his lines from other
movies and in this case he definitely
did this and it's from a movie that came
out ten years before Dogma came out
number four what is the name of Cardinal
glicks
PR campaign
I'm all of this well what is the name of
Cardinal Experian and number five
closing out the Smithsonian Museum round
of all dogma questions according to IMDB
who was originally cast as God
prompting Jay to refer to the piano when
he first sees her so originally somebody
else was supposed to play God
the IMDB is technically the wrong she
wasn't cast but to shoot it was written
for somebody the part of God was written
for and it's the reason that Jay makes a
piano joke in the movie if you know that
write it down on that little card ladies
and gentlemen because that is the fifth
and final question in the Smithsonian
Museum round that gets us through all
your dogma questions when you fill out
your card hold it up Big Daddy Jimmy V
Gordon eight will collect it I assure
you they will take it into the back and
they will figure out who is the smartest
in the room when it comes to Kevin Smith
I would have won this round hands down
yeah you did better only your questions
about you this time then you did that
last time
I know I was paying more attention this
time around I'm glad you're here to
correct the IMDB when the IMDB got it
wrong when the IMDB said that I'm always
here to correct the I'm JP but you never
have to because they're always good
always so good it is one of the most
excellent outfits that I can imagine
do you remember what life was like
before you could [ __ ] look up
people's names like you know be like who
played there was life before that no no
we used to have to think real [ __ ]
hard there it is folks if your cards are
not handed in the next five seconds
you're gonna miss out five four three
two one [ __ ] that round it's over but
your hand together folks we accomplished
something I don't even need the answer
key for these ready okay how much money
does Rufus claim Jesus owes him twelve
bucks
twelve bucks twelve bucks that is a that
is a ad-libbed line I did not write the
line particularly what comes in the
first half of the line Chris Rock at
that line in the moment and I remember
talking to him afterwards I was like
it's a great [ __ ] line I can't use it
in the movie and he goes why I was like
cuz what am I supposed to do write on
the script written by Kevin Smith with
one line by Chris Rock and he goes just
don't [ __ ] ever tell anybody
well too late for that yeah here we go
number two
William Donohue ran what organization
that famously protested dog without
seeing it that would be the Catholic
League the Catholic the Catholic League
was the answer we were looking for
number three Silent Bob's lying on the
train is a reference to what movie that
came out ten years before why that was
Indiana Jones and the Last Crusade and
the line was no ticket no ticket number
four what is the name of Cardinal glitz
PR campaign that would be Catholicism
Wow with an exclamation point exactly
right the vollis ISM won't take it
without the exclamation point and number
five according to IMDB who was
originally cast as God
prompting Jay to refer to the movie the
piano when he first sees her and that
answer of course is Holly Hunter hunter
it was written for Holly Hunter because
she passed on it because she had just
done a movie with well maybe she passed
like she was like I don't like the
script but she told us she passed on it
cuz she had just done an angel movie
with Danny Boyle what was the movie he
did after Trainspotting a life less
ordinary I think it was called yes in
which she played in an assassin angel oh
that's so funny her and what Delroy
Lindo I think was the other one so she
was like I just played an angel so I
don't want to play God so according to
IMDB it was because she was pregnant no
that's a different story
Emma Thompson originally agreed to play
God Alan Rickman was like Emma
Thompson's a friend of mine and she
loved to play God and I was like call
her call her and so she was in and then
she was out he was only that was
frightening she and I got it right a
note which I found recently and she
wrote it on Emma Thompson stationery has
an elephant on it and it was about like
hey I wanted to do this so badly I love
Allen I think the script is funny but
I'm gonna try to have a kid so I'm
bow out and and so I didn't this early
days of the internet like 1998 we were
shooting that movie so you know I
[ __ ] wrote on our message board like
Oh Emma Thompson was gonna play God but
she's gonna try to have a baby so she
cannot going to play God she's gonna
drop out and the next day like everyone
showed up at her front door in England
going like are you having a baby baby so
she called up and she was like could you
not tell people what I say yeah oh my
god I'm so sorry
any event you got a winner we have two
teams that got four answers correct on
so who teams competing for this [ __ ]
signed by Kevin Smith and Jason Mewes
monopoly edition Jay and Silent Bob
strike back what are the two teams give
me one representative from each of the
following teams and Raquel fish quiz
award on up here and qui gonn gin and
tonic qui gonn Jenna Donna get up here
you're playing for the ultimate booty
all right this is the word association
will go back and forth with this one
this is the back and forth man face each
other in the Octagon of death as Andy
gives you a word association game that
he's at the ready you ready yeah [ __ ]
you you got it the category here is name
movies where animals talk okay three
seconds between each go
yes yes he got immensely done give it up
for me one monopoly man that's [ __ ]
tough man it's like you crumble in the
moment cuz you're like oh my god animals
they're in every movie and then I'll
soon you're like wait a second like I
was thrown by secret of NIMH that would
have thrown me I was like [ __ ] secret
of NIMH where'd that come from I think
once you get to Madagascar you're gonna
do a whole run that's true
alright man that was round seven round
eight is about to begin ladies and
gentlemen and round eight I can't get my
papers open what rat what is round 80
it's the Kessel run the Kessel run
special in our hearts here at the scum
and villainy Cantina that's right here
at the scum and villainy Cantina we all
get to take the Kessel run together
round eight what we're playing for
ladies and gentlemen is a very specific
yet cool prize these are a pair of bb-8
sneakers yes they're made by a company
called pose ooh what size size 43 in
Europe yeah under what that means we're
Dantooine what I would imagine if they
were given to me tens I think they're
nine fives or ten somewhere in that
category so I never warm brand new pair
BB eights man and they Kevin got them
because bb-8 could not wear them he
tried that joke on me at home you gotta
laugh you tested it out on me no I was
being used all right here we go
let's all take the Kessel run together
put your [ __ ] phones down get your
[ __ ] pens up and get ready to take
this test number one the cell block in
Episode four is a reference to what
George Lucas film come on any Star Wars
fan worth their salt knows this don't
make them feel bad don't look it up
you don't need to look this up you know
it number two according to George Lucas
at
2015 convention who or what is Jar Jar
Binks based on George Lucas was at a
2015 competitors and he said in response
to a question I would imagine who or
what is Jar Jar Binks based on number
three what Star Wars character did JJ
Abrams stick in star trek into darkness
two years before making the force
awakens I didn't know are you are you
saying that there is a Star Wars
character in a Star Trek movie is that
true that is true Wow
what stars I'm gonna learn something
today what Star Wars character did JJ
Abrams stick into Star Trek into
darkness
two years before making the force
awakens and it's a character it is
interesting look forward to the answer
for this
you have you have intrigued me I've
piqued your interest and you really have
what character did Simon Pegg play in
the force awakens will you do you need a
name or will you take that that guy we
need a name I mean it's a pretty Star
Wars centric place did not get that but
I thought was my little more JJ Abrams
crossover with Scotty playing a
character in because Simon Pegg played
Scotty in Star Trek right but that's not
that's not the question the question is
what did he play in the force awakens
right but he's not the answer to three
is he no no answer to three is an actual
Star Wars character appears on screen in
star trek into darkness really yes Wow
it's a little Easter Egg they stuck in
there to make people make me go number
five what force awakens character was
inspired by a hip-hop album that would
be the character's name JJ Abrams big
fan of this group particularly
that's right I remember this man what
force awakens character is inspired by a
hip-hop album we just took the Kessel
run together ladies gentlemen god bless
you if you have answered all those
questions and written them down on your
little pink houses hold them up in the
air
Big Daddy Jimmy V Nate they will collect
these from you you said little pink
houses little big houses for you and me
the cards are pink this week some of the
cards are pink I was just getting all
sorts of slangy with it man okay well I
was getting I was acting like a hep cat
I was being hipster my bad
you brought a little fun into it I did
into a very brain-busting round for some
folks I I wear a lot of jackets now yes
so I've been wearing a lot of pins so I
got into like you know [ __ ] like I've
collected pins mullet but I haven't worn
them in years because I have morning
jacket so I know it's a Disneyland like
that's all they [ __ ] do now is sell
pins right right that whole pin trade I
bought so many [ __ ] pins like it was
crazy I bought a bunch of pins I had no
idea that I would walk away with as many
pins as I bought my dad wasn't making
fun of me and she loves Disney and still
she was just like that's an awful lot of
yes that's gonna be a 60-pound jacket
based on does everybody handed in their
cards we're gonna count five seconds
then end this god-awful round 5 400 3 2
1 [ __ ] the Kessel run it's over put your
hands together folks all right Andy the
cellblock in Cell Block in episode 4 is
a reference to what George Lucas film
I'm gonna say thx 1-1 3-8
Robert Duvall in thx 1-1 3-8 I'm
cellblock 1-1 3-8 Josh bush-league
cellblock is actually a a 20 Skywalker
says prisoner transfer from cell block
1-1 3-8 when the lieutenant asks where
what are they doing with Chewbacca
where
you taking this thing Luke says so
prisoner transfer from cell block one
one three but you didn't already own
this bar you would win those sneakers
yeah anyway so now the internet doesn't
have to yell at you because I yes but we
know where you're looking for but
everybody knows we were looking for the
cell block that he talks about but what
happened to write the real cell block on
that ah Jimmy they are right we will
take both answers where'd you go tell
those guys sweetie thank you he saved
your ass here we go number two according
to George Lucas at a 2015 convention who
or what is Jar Jar Binks based on
anybody get this one goofy goofy
he said that pump said that he said I
love goofy and I love Jar Jar Binks was
how he ended that speech and then
everyone sat there with their mouths
open for two days like now it makes
sense
imagine me cigars all right number three
what Star Wars character did JJ Abrams
stick into star trek into darkness two
years before a force awakens r2d2 is
aware during a battle scene the debris
floats by the control room window and
part of the debris is r2d2 11 minutes 12
seconds at 11 minutes to 12 seconds good
to know all right that should have been
the question number four what character
did Simon Pegg play in the force awakens
I'm he played the big suit guy but I'm
the big fat guy unkar plutt like our
plot we got some luck our flat fans and
what was his name unkar plutt so you
needed the exact name well this is name
no no doubts so maybe you guys flapped
you knew it yeah everyone else was dead
silent so I feel like you guys might
have the corner of the market on
yeah Wow I'm car plots on car plus oh
man plots kid that ones why yes there's
a judgment to be made there okay so then
the last let me see question was what
force awakens character was inspired by
hip hop album ello nasty or at hello
nasty by the Beastie Boys and they took
the first letter off of each name and
made it ello Asty so ello Asty and the
trivia a lot of people thought that he
was referencing the show lost ello Asty
oh it was not it was actually from the
Beastie Boys this is kind of a twofer at
the end of the day s around we have to
Kessler run round we have two winners no
wait so I will take a reference we do
not we do not have two winners we don't
that was an incorrect answer it needed a
judgement from the line judge and I am
saying we have one winner and it is
quite on Jena tonic oh my god [ __ ]
come get your shoes man you want some
bb-8 well done congratulation you guys
are cleaning the [ __ ] up ok round 9
folks is the Funko pop round popped me
in the mouth man what you're going to
win in this round is a signed Kevin
Smith pop from Jay & Silent Bob's secret
stash comic book store out in Red Bank
New Jersey it is it's it's yours for the
taking if you get this round correct man
the Funko pop around popped me in the
mouth round is all pop culture questions
pop culture questions so what is the
there's no theme these we jump around we
want to be current in the last year some
potpourri of pot if you will it's a
toss-up here we go number one phones
down pens up what did Mark bridges win
at the Oscars this year for having the
shortest acceptance speech I remember
this they gave out a prize the shortest
except it's not the Oscar it is another
prize what did Mark Bridges win at the
Oscars this year for having the shortest
acceptance speech
it was a gag that they were a running
gag what I had that was was not that
great number two what is alec baldwin's
wipes first name i got a young wife
she's got a pretty famous name and we
will see if people know it I don't know
it at all what is Alec Baldwin's wife's
first name number three where did
Lindsay Lohan open her new bar had
selection on this one I only know this
because we talked about on Babylon this
weekend yeah just recently where did lo
at Lindsay Lohan Lindsay Lohan open her
new bar you're saying that if people
here listen to Hollywood babble-on
they'd be able to get all the answers in
this one and they might man if we talk
about pop culture they're quite a bit
Hollywood babble-on ladies and gentlemen
at the Hollywood improv every Friday and
or Saturday night number four who wrote
the Aretha Franklin hit respect we're
about to learn something I didn't know
this really yes and he recorded it first
it's a guy it is a guy he's narrowed it
down
who wrote the Aretha Franklin hit
respect and he recorded before are3 yes
and she she's stolen she took it made it
her own with this with his blessing and
everything like wow she really made her
own and number five what character did
Brad Pitt play in Deadpool - Brad Pitt I
just watch the scene on video so I know
this answer what character - Brad Pitt
playing Deadpool - fun movie very fun
movies one of my favorites
I enjoyed it quite a bit I didn't like
it as much as the first one but x-force
there it is folks round 9 Funko pop pop
and in those cards we're all done man if
you hand in those cars will start
telling you what the correct answers to
all those questions were if you're done
filling out your card hold it up and hey
Nate we'll grab it
Big Daddy Jimmy V he'll grab it talking
about your cards right there Nate
collecting
some cards like them don't trade them to
go figure out who the winners are but
you're all winners in all of our hearts
but we got to pick somebody and get the
questions right is that it
countdown five seconds folks five four
three two one
bucket it's over put your hands together
we did it human endeavor round nine
folks number one question what did Mark
bridges win at the Oscars this year for
having the shortest acceptance speech
jet ski he won a Kawasaki jet ski and C
do is not correct Kawasaki jet ski so
you wouldn't I'm not taking C do no ski
I'm gonna take a CD from nobody now I
feel your myth number two all right pipe
down number two don't jump out of your
manager Bank what is alec baldwin's
wife's first name what a weird question
will we her name is hilarious her name
is hilarya is that first name is hilarya
did people know that did you guys get
that do it that's like an Us Magazine
kind of factoid did you pick that up
from like oh how did you grow I do once
you hear her name you don't forget I
used to I'll never forget now number
three where did Lindsay Lohan open her
new bar the Greek island of Mykonos
Mykonos mikonos
Greece is not close enough Mamma Mia
thing over there yes
here she goes again who wrote the Aretha
Franklin hit respect they'll be Otis
Redding Otis Redding wrote that song
reporter first and when she sang it and
he heard her recording before it was
released he said it's not my song
anymore so it was he did he ever release
it uh he didn't release it actually yes
you can listen to it but she is the one
that really made it huge Wow
Otis Redding and then number five what
character did Brad Pitt play in Deadpool
two and I think you know this one Kevin
it was the invisible one Vanisher the
banner sure the Vanisher for a brief
moment when he's electrocuted here's old
Brad Pitt smile
it's camera alright man we jumped all
over with that category well done Andy
put your hands together for Andy McElroy
hey I'll take it
it was windy like a lot of the other
ones are all themed and stuff like that
but that one was so you have to use all
parts of your brain you did used every
part even the tongue all right is that
just one one correct card and we will
find out we will take a representative
from the following team because that
team won and that team is uh Kison boss
uh Kison boss hey Andy once said boss
came you're walking away with a little
pop in the mouth man alright folks we're
at the last round the most important
round there's the shirt off my
background the winner of this round is
gonna win this shirt that I'm wearing
right now you're gonna walk away with
this fine tuxedo jersey of mine man the
very first one I ever made in this style
I got another one at home but this one
will be yours it's a one-of-a-kind but
almost yes it is literally a
one-of-a-kind but I got another one like
I'm gonna give you see what I'm going
with it fair enough
round 10 show off my background the
questions the answers all have to do
with back yes usually so explain this
one well well so often times be like we
picked movie the movie backdraft and we
picked Jim Backus the very very famous
and well-known and all the his life
well-known things yes and in this case
I'm calling this little game because
you'd like to make these hard behind the
colon and what this is is sequels where
the name of the movie comes first a
colon and then something went back in it
okay
and a good example of that would be Star
Wars Episode five the Empire Strikes
Back so where's the coal in there Star
Wars Episode five : the Empire Strikes
Back so get behind those colons we are
you went a long way for that but I have
a lot that kind of shoe leather on that
give it up Randy man he made a dirty
joke no joke no joke too small no no all
right so these sequels have back in
their title after the colon named the
movie so I read that and then they have
to tell they have to write how the
franchise is you know the first movie
here we go number one folks back in the
habit
everybody movie title colon back in the
habit we're looking for what happened
before the colon yes number two a small
intestine if you will yeah if you're on
the inside if you're on the outside
before the colon is may I
Wow it's a matter of number two back in
business back back in business
thinking about movie with a number of
different in this case two different
films it's ringing a bell but I can't
remember this one is I'm confounded on
number three Spike's back and I only put
this in because I saw this I know I got
a copy of it and it was not enough
Spike's back is the movie ladies
gentlemen number four back in action
back in action
oh that sounds so generic it could be
famous big movie back in action
and number five boy you make this this
is a hard one right they make it very
hard to win this shirt mm-hmm
number five back in training back in
training so evidently yes some sort of
group of people who got a laugh out of
mate for the train you know what it is
they they've trained their day now
they're back in training number one back
in the habit number two back in business
number three spikes back to before back
in action number five back in training
that is the end of the shirt off my
background ladies and gentlemen if you
finish filling out your card hold it in
the air
Big Daddy Jimmy V or perhaps Nate will
collect it they'll bring it into the
back which is really the front they'll
tabulate the [ __ ] out of it and the
winner of this round is gonna walk away
with this Jersey this very Jersey that
I'm wearing right now in fact if you
give me a sharpie I'll sign it JC you
got a Sharpie laying around
you got one I'll take it thank you you
whip it here if it hits me in the eye so
babe
thank you I'm gonna sign this [ __ ] right
now folks
Kevin Smith write down my titties it's
waiting for you man thank you nicely
done thank you sir
we collect all cards well the cards are
in this round is about to end in five
four three one more card all right Thank
You JC thank you so much all right man I
am I'm real I want you to I want these I
don't know a lot of these I need your
help I need your leadership number one
back in the habit easily sister act 2
Sister Act two ladies in round two is
the answer Act two number two back in
business
barbershop two two back in business we
have a barbershop fan up front
number three spikes back I am ashamed to
say I watched this movie it is Air Bud
Spike's back and let me tell you the
plot Gabrielle Reece meets Air Bud and
she somehow she's a famous volleyball
player and she doesn't play volleyball
so now instead of playing basketball
he's now able to spike the ball with his
little golden retriever nose they took
that dog in a lot of directions
yes it's true Liam but it also started
the great Edie McClurg who was mrs.
Stapleton on rocket power so I watched
that boom you worked with the enemy I
did she's you know of Ferris Bueller of
course yes of course all right and
number four back in action that would be
Looney Tunes back in action
we go Looney Tunes back in action the
Jenna Elfman plays the bad guy in that's
right it was fairly recent right like
last 10 years it feels like it's still
too soon and then number five back in
training this made Nate laugh out loud
where do you train why at a police
academy that's where these Academy there
it is man we've gone through it and
stuff and now we're just waiting for the
results to come in
how am I mean I guess the sky's the
limit for coming up with back categories
but what it's actually not the limit
yeah actually very limited cat it would
imagine there's a glass ceiling just one
winner one winner ladies and gentlemen
is gonna walk away with the shirt that
I'm wearing on my back this team needs
to send a representative up here and
he's gonna tell you what it is and that
team is solo solo nicely done good job
good job we're from the same state give
it up for him ladies gentlemen all right
now at the end of this thing with ten
rounds we've got winners for each round
but that also means that there's a
winner for the entire game is that
correct that's correct we have actually
two prizes to give away at the end the
first one being the wooden spoon and
we'd asked it's JC if he has a wooden
spoon I can see him sprinting around the
bar the wooden spoon is given to the
team that sucked the most yes one goes
to the team that lost now the team with
the fewest correct answers the ones with
the most wrong answers oh look at that
Oh sticks for you three here give me a
sharpie I'll sign them the booby prize
is three signed glowing sticks how do
they work man and what are they for they
have to play off okay don't give this
away this is cool
you're gonna win this [ __ ] if you're the
worst in the room oh there's different
speeds this is good [ __ ] man you're
gonna win a pretty good prize better
than the real one here we go tell him
who the Battle of it a lot more if you
won the raw round I can say that okay
who wins the wooden spoon this week why
it's the guy from Montreal
the guy from Montreal come on over guy
from Montreal and collect your winnings
your earnings your giveaways will you
buy yourself are you from my drive from
Montreal oh well you you did it sir you
did you walk away with three sticks take
all three man you'll make friends
instantly look how fun that is give it
up for a man approach and now there's a
real winner isn't there somebody that
won the most rounds of the day fast
Kevin Smith there's two teams the tied
for first so wait what are we having do
a runoff
so in this dramatis really that this is
the ionic finish to our exciting game
this is exciting
alright so two teams have come in they
each have to send a representative up to
face each other on how many wins did
they have a piece before we bring them
up list each one two rounds out of ten
all right so I could probably guess who
these cats are do it one of them would
be sukkah sand boss okay that's it or
boss boss and the other would be
quiz four dogs I'm sorry it's qui-gon
jinn and tonic why ganja man Tommy I
know it supplies them we'll take a
representative from each one of those
teams come up here man congratulations
congratulations played in the Spielberg
faceoff round so I want to do that I
want to do that category again okay
this is the what you're playing for it's
the education challenge coin the edge of
a challenge coin right now it's made of
wood like a Wooden Nickel and stuff but
of course once our metal coins come in
you could replace it with that is that
is correct or if you love the
handcrafted by myself version you can
keep that this enables the winner
to do what Andy why every time they come
to the scum and villainy Cantigny to
play our game they get all 10 rounds of
question cards for free you never have
to pay again I believe there's what two
teams three teams here three teams have
and we rapidly rapidly running out of
making money on the three teams playing
this week played for free because they
got these men so you guys gonna be
playing for this and this is the back
and forth game it is so it's the word
association kind of game you will have
three seconds to respond between if
you'd be if you don't beat the clock
then the other guy wins category is
Spielberg movies started gonna get her
this go the edge of my challenge coin is
yours my friend you could trade it in
for the metal one when they're done or
you could keep the wooden one that's
yours what does it enable them to do it
enables them to come back and play with
us anytime for free there you go give it
up for the big winner ladies and
gentlemen boy oh boy that was [ __ ]
good man that was a good [ __ ] yeah it
was nice to see and I was a hard
question finding out that Donald Trump
was going to play the president in
sharknado 3 was all worthwhile something
worth knowing ladies and gentleman jail
have a good time today none of this is
possible without JC and the good folks
here at the scum and villainy Cantina
give it up for a
and we would literally have nothing to
talk about
if the quizmaster didn't do his job for
six hours of questions give it up for
Professor Andrew McHale fresh and that
is education for this week I'm Kevin
Smith and I'm Andy McHale friend you
have been edging Makeda good night
everybody
[Applause]